[Music]  Kim Kardashian has a no tolerance policy  when it comes to rumors okay guys so I'm  so excited to show you our new kids drop  on the kid supplies calm on Monday the  36 year old mom of 2 took to snapchat to  tease her and hubby Kanye West's  upcoming fashion lines her first product  is this collab with a kid north and  Penelope's favorite slides how cute  Leopard but while Kim might have been  stoked for the new clothes which  launched Monday I mean hello it seems a  few fans were more concerned with the  white powder on the table behind her and  questioned whether the substance was  cocaine Kim wasn't pleased with the  accusations and quickly set the record  straight tweeting I do not play with  rumors like this so I'm gonna shut it  down real quick not sugar from our candy  mess from Dylan's candy shop  [Music]  you